jonathan roland 15 ans fait partie des
jeunes présents ce samedi 25 février
pour la finale de la coupe d'hiver au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
le pistard licencié au vélo club de
montigny le bretonneux à participer à
l'omnium avec trois épreuves au
programme
l'élimination la course aux points et le
scratch c'est quand même vraiment bien
parce que sur piste il ya très peu de
compétition surtout dans un vélodrome
comme ça ça veulent aux romains très
moderne en plus tout neuf qui accueille
beaucoup d'évènements mondiaux et
internationaux et e
donc moi je trouve ça vraiment génial
qu'une confession faut organiser ici
après avoir commencé le cyclisme sur
route en 2013 au vcmb jonathan s'élancer
sur la piste il ya seulement deux ans
cette compétition lui permet donc
d'acquérir de l'expérience dans cette
nouvelle discipline ses rangs une
pression qui est différente sur la route
que sur la route
donc c'est vraiment important de gérer
ça et donc surtout que là on est revenu
il ya beaucoup de spectateurs donc on a
vraiment envie de bien faire du côté de
l'organisation les sept clubs
franciliens participants espèrent
pouvoir découvrir des jeunes talents
avec cette coupe d'hiver parmi ces
jeunes il y a des gens de grande qualité
des gens qui s'expriment
la vocation de cette coupe
d'île de france c'est de permettre à des
jeunes talents de s'exprimer pour
alimenter les sélections régionales
nationales et pourquoi pas les équipes
de france ce samedi jonathan rolland a
terminé à la 12e place sur 24
participants le cycliste devrait sans
doute revenir l'année prochaine pour la
deuxième édition de la coupe d'hiver
afin d'améliorer son classement
[Musique]